ja das Thema was ich heute mitgebracht
habe ist das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz mit enthalten
in einer in einem großen
Entlastungspaket dabei ist es gar keine
Entlastung sondern es ist die
Verhinderung einer steigenden Belastung
Inflation
Inflationsausgleich heißt dort eben den
Start sich nicht zusätzlich bereichern
zu lassen sondern das Geld bei den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zu lassen
Kaufkraft zu erhalten das hat die FDP
ich glaube auch an der Stelle wieder ein
bisschen gegen die Vorstellung unserer
Koalitionspartner durchgesetzt und unser
Vorschlag ist es jetzt an der Stelle das
nicht alle zwei Jahre neu zu diskutieren
und sozusagen in die Wilke der dann
jeweiligen Regierung das zu überlassen
sondern es zu automatisieren das ist
auch die Erfahrung die der
Bundesfinanzminister gerade macht wenn
er mit seinen europäischen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen spricht wenn die im
Austausch sind da heißt es Deutschland
macht ja ein relativ großes
Entlastungspaket und dann beschreibt er
eben dass er da auch an die Steuer
rangeht und dann gucken in alle mit
großen Augen an weil die sagen bei uns
ist das ganz automatisch also es ist
eben ein Teil jetzt hier mit
Leistungspaket aber wir brauchen das
zukünftig als Automatismus dass die
Steuerzahlungen Steuerzahler nicht auf
die Wirkung der Regierung angewiesen
sind Herr fahnold wie würden sie das
einschätzen was die FDP plant und macht
haben sie es verstanden was die machen
ja also der Ansatz ist ja richtig das
kann ja nicht sein dass durch Inflation
sozusagen der Staat zum zum Gewinner
wird und dann aber großzügig wieder das
verteilt und dann sozusagen sich damit
politische Zustimmung gekauft insofern
finde ich es absolut richtig weil wir
bestrafen ja Leistungen wir bestrafen ja
sogar diejenigen die das gleiche
verdienen aber durch die Inflation
natürlich sogar dann ein Ausgleich
kriegen aber das kassiert dann der Staat
wieder zum großen da da hat er völlig
Recht und ich finde ein Automatismus
finde ich sehr begrüßen will also ich
finde aber ich darf noch mal sagen was
was
also wirklich heute abend berührt ist
etwas was ich doch mal aufgreifen will
dass wir eine ganze Generation verlieren
das sollten wir wirklich noch mal in der
Mittelpunkt stellen und sagen Leute die
in den Medien tätig sind da meine ich
wirklich alle anderen außer dieser
Sendung wenn ihr glaubt dass ihr mit den
Tagesthemen irgendwas bewirkt wenn ihr
über den Waldbrand in Pakistan berichtet
und nicht das in einen Zusammenhang
spricht dann habt ihr am Ende
Kinder die verzweifelt werden dass das
ist etwas wo wir wirklich lernen müssen
wir sind in einer schwierigen Lage da
kann es doch nicht angehen dass wir doch
mehr verunsichern ich fakt ist das weiß
das wissen die meisten nicht die Zahl
der weit werden ist zurückgegangen die
Todesopfer durch Waldbrände seit 50
Jahren zurückgegangen die waren früher
500.000 im Jahr jetzt sind sie bei
20.000 vor 10 Jahren jetzt sind sie bei
7.000 das heißt der Mensch hat viel mehr
sich darauf ein können das gleiche geht
für Flutkatastrophen wir wir haben den
Eindruck das wird alles immer schlimmer
weil wir jeden Tag eine
Berichterstattung von was weiß ich heute
ist Argentinien morgen Australien dran
aber wenn Sie die Statistiken die
wissenschaftlichen Statistiken sehen
dann sind die Wetter extreme die
Todesfälle durch Wetter extreme
zurückgegangen
das ist Fakt und deswegen mussten wir
doch mal zu Ordnung rufen und sagen
Leute was wollt ihr eigentlich damit
bezwecken wenn der die Leute so
verunsichert dass es am Ende eine ganze
Generation gibt die sich lieber anklebt
als den Mut zu haben Neues zu wagen und
da müssen wir glaube ich bei den Medien
anfangen aber auch bei der Politik die
das dann gerne nutzt um dann sozusagen
Angst zu erzeugen das geht dann so weit
dass man sagt naja weil das Klima uns
sozusagen demnächst
für die Jugend einen verpflichtendes
soziales Jahr vor das soll es dann
retten ja vielleicht hätten sie mal
vielleicht bei der Wehrpflicht bleiben
sollen dann wenn das dann vielleicht
auch dann dann hätte man das auch mit
erschlagen aber wir müssen glaube ich
tatsächlich hier innehalten weil wir
verlieren eine ganze Generation
das hat mich sehr bewegt was sie sagen
und ich glaube wir müssen da wirklich
auch diejenigen abstrafen die glauben
mit dieser Politik politische Ziele
durchzusetzen nicht dass wir das Auto in
Deutschland die gesamte
Automobilindustrie zerstören mit der
Angst dass uns dann am Ende wir
verantwortlich sind für eine
Klimakatastrophe wo wir 2% Anteile haben
das ist unverantwortlich ja und eine
ganze Generation abzuschreiben nur weil
man seine parteipolitischen Ziele damit
besser durchsetzen kann mit Angst wird
Politik gemacht in Deutschland und das
muss beendet werden Herr Braun was kann
die Politik tun wenn Sie das Hören mit
den Fakten auch mit Blick auf den
Klimawandel wo ist die Aufgabe für ihre
Partei und generell die Politiker in
diesem Land also wenn es jetzt heißt die
Politik macht Angst das tut mir leider
der mich meiner Partei ausdrücklich aus
ich glaube wir haben schon ein
Optimismus auch im Herzen und tragen ihn
auch nach außen und versuchen nicht Land
und Menschen schlecht zu reden um dann
selber stark dazustehen sondern schon zu
sagen wir wollen jedem die Chance geben
sein eigenes Leben auch zu leben so wie
er es möchte und genau da ist ja der
Punkt Friedrich Merz wurde ja heute
schon auch positiv angesprochen deswegen
können wir an der Stelle jetzt auch mal
kritisieren also jetzt mit einem
verpflichtenden gesellschaftsjahr um die
Ecke zu kommen überhaupt die Vorstellung
zu haben der Staat hat das Recht bei
einem jungen Menschen sich ein Jahr
seines Lebens zu nehmen wir sprechen
über Fachkräftemangel wir sprechen über
eine Generation die gerade wir haben
vorhin über die Maßnahmen gesprochen
weggesperrt war in den letzten Jahren
viele junge Menschen erleben gerade
gesagt damit also unser Justizminister
damit wurde der Jugend schon ein Jahr
enteignet ja die Corona viele haben
jetzt in diesem Jahr das erste mal Dinge
erlebt die sie eben in den letzten
Jahren nicht erleben konnten und ich
erhalte das nicht für einen offenen Bild
den jungen Leuten zu sagen morgen was
weiß ich bei mir in Brandenburg jetzt
Beelitz 8 Uhr suchte aus Kaserne oder
Altenheim das ist es dann das kannst du
sagen
ihrer Partei ist wer auch schlimm wenn
nicht wenn Sie jetzt hier gegen die
fdp-wettern würden aber die Politik als
ganze verstehen sie denn da die Kritik
von erfahren heute nehmen wir jetzt mal
die FDP aus das schenke ich Ihnen ja nee
das ist mir schon wichtig weil ich das
schon erlebe wir hatten ja vorhin auch
bisschen Kritik in die in Richtung
Medium das Zusammenspiel mit Politik um
jetzt mal einen anderen Unionspolitiker
zu nehmen also wenn sich einen Markus
Söder auf die Bühne stellt und sich über
die Frisur von Toni Hofreiter lustig
machen das kann man alles machen bei
Markus und Toni hofreit gemacht alles
bei Parteien Kritik sondern wir sind bei
Fakten Klimawandel wie kann die Politik
das besser vermitteln weil ich kann
Ihnen sagen was den Bürger richtig
aufregt wenn die Politiker sich immer
nur noch gegenseitig schlecht machen
anstatt vielleicht mal über Fakten und
Lösungen zu überlegen und das wollen wir
jetzt also wir nehmen den Case jetzt von
ihr fahren heute wie könnte denn die
Politik mehr Fakten an den Bürger
bringen auch was den Klimawandel
betrifft ich glaube schon dass es
wichtig ist dann vor allem auch mal in
der Diskussion zu gehen und auch mal
Politiker zum Anfassen zu erleben ich
glaube das haben wir heute viel zu
selten ich glaube gerade die Generation
über die wir sprechen Tagesschau wurde
genannt die guckt nicht
die guckt
die guckt nicht
regierungspressekonferenzen dreimal in
der Woche und ist auch sonst wir müssen
die Dinge
Bundestag ich habe Helmut Schmidt
gesehen ich habe Wehner gesehen ich habe
sie alle im Fernsehen verfolgt als
Jugendlicher und ich fand das total
spannend heute wird eine Sprache
gesprochen die kein Kind mehr versteht
ich habe während der Regierungserklärung
eben bei Frau Merkel als es um die
corona-maßnahmen ging das für unsere
Familien übersetzt weil die Sprache wird
nicht mehr verstanden wir haben eine
bürokratische Sprache die das Volk sag
ich mal so krass kaum noch versteht wir
haben Anträge die kein Sozialpädagoge
von mir ausfüllen und das sind studierte
Leute und da muss man sich nicht wundern
dass sowas im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Fernsehen oder wo auch immer auch gar
nicht angeguckt wird weil die weil für
viele Menschen sind das böhmische Dörfer
was da Fach gesimpelt wird und was
wirklich am Bürger vorbei geht ich meine
überlegen Sie mal wer kann denn
verstehen wenn ich richtig informiert
bin korrigieren Sie mich hat die neue
Bundesregierung 750 neue Mitarbeiter
gebraucht eingestellt um arbeiten zu
können und jetzt mit dieser Regierung
arbeiten zu können wie soll ein Bürger
das Verstehen der sagt wir haben so
wenig Geld in der eigenen Tasche und die
Bundesregierung braucht jetzt so viel
staatliches Geld um das auszugeben wenn
wir anfangen mal ein bisschen
transparenter zu sein auch in der
Politik dann wird es auch einfacher sein
dass der Bürger die Politik ernster
nimmt ich glaube das ist der Schlüssel
und auch die Kinder dass die Kinder
verstehen was da oben passiert dazu
müssen die eben auch mehr ins Boot
genommen werden
und umgekehrt die Politiker sind häufig
die haben Abitur gemacht und dann sind
sie zügig mit ein bisschen Studium und
gerade unsere derzeitige Regierung auch
mit abgebrochenen Studien dann in die
Politik als Berufspolitiker gegangen sie
sind nicht beide Leute dieses dass das
Leute sein müssen die fast verstehen